first of all congrats on the movie
um i had a blast uh did you
uh do you think that the characters in
this movie have seen the jurassic park
films
because i don't know if they actually
have learned from any of those kind of
movies
i think uh yeah they've probably seen
him but maybe they're just
too naive on
they nathan my character somehow thinks
that
uh well first of all like
getting kong off of skull island is
something they have to do because he
you know he he is in a biodome
um and that he can't sustain him for
much longer so
they're kind of desperate uh to get him
off
uh off of skull island and then
it's it's it's a tough challenge because
again uh
godzilla is wreaking havoc out there so
we're gonna take him and the idea said
well
hollow earth is a theory that that
kong's ancestors
uh originated from there so so and they
believe
that they found a path through the
pacific
that is not um in in
in godzilla's territorial waters on
so so perhaps slightly
naively they believe that well if we we
we have a window now where we can
transport kong down to
antarctica without godzilla uh
noticing it completely i'm gonna i'm
gonna ask you this is this is a fun
question so bear with me
um so every time we write about godzilla
versus khan
on collider uh what happens is that all
the commenters leave the same thing
which is
why don't they just kiss so i'm just
curious
if uh director adam wingard ever told
you uh
why don't godzilla and kong kiss
[Laughter]
we uh i think the way to tell that story
you want that kiss to to mean something
and and in order to do that as you know
when you tell a story
there's got to be like a way into it you
and
there's no better way no better build up
than
an acrimonious relationship when they're
fighting and it's it's
tough and they you know because then
it's so much more of a
a a an explosion when they finally do
kiss you're like it's happening that you
know they've been
fighting and trying to kill each other
and now it's that finally happening so
in any love story in any uh
you know that's what you want you want
to see that like the kind of the
friction and the tension and then
so what i'm trying to say is basically i
think that this is like a two-hour build
up
of them fighting going at it and then
the sequel
it's just gonna be lovemaking
the greatest then you've you've earned
it you know you have you've earned it
completely listen i completely agree
i i can only imagine for you when you're
making a movie like this it really
requires your imagination
and it must be really crazy to see the
finished film
where you're seeing the finished vfx and
getting to watch them fight
what was it like for you actually seeing
the finished movie and watching them
fight
it's almost like you're not in the movie
because like you said even though we
have
storyboards and pre-visualizations that
you can that we looked at before
shooting those scenes to have an idea of
what we're reacting to
it looks completely different a year
later when they've done
all you know added all the special
effects and the the mixing and the
editing and the sound and
it is um
like i said you you basically forget
that you're in the movie so
when i watched it i i i watched it like
a member of the audience basically
because um it it i
it obviously looks completely different
from on the day when we shot it when
we're
standing there on a green screen with a
tennis ball in front of us
completely i gotta go i'm just gonna say
i'm really looking forward to the
northmen
oh appreciate it man i um it was an
extraordinary experience oh i i can't
wait for you guys to see it
i cannot wait to talk to you about it on
that note i'll see you
later this year hopefully i'll talk
about the northmen